so your new season of Vanderpump Like
rules like what what's going on what's a
tease for us it was so complicated you
know and it kind of blew up out of the
stratosphere I mean it was just so crazy
it was a lot of bad behavior the season
before and we tried to sort it out but
we'd stopped filming when it was all
exposed so we need this season this
season feels very different to any other
season to sort it out and as the kind of
matriarch do you ever watch the show
you're looking at me like maybe you do
no I'm I'm just fascinated by everything
you do I'm like yeah like what don't you
do it's insane oh there's a couple of
things house my
[Laughter]
husband it's the Bri hum I I have so
many
jokes they're so wasted right now God I
wish this was night time show well we
need another commercial break everybody
watch Vanderpump rolls Tuesdays on Bravo
and streaming on peacock
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home